hello everyone welcome to the winescape
podcast i'm your host sean carroll today
we're going to have nigel goldenfeld on
the podcast nigel is a leading condensed
matter physicist now we have physics all
the time here on mindscape but we don't
really do condensed matter that much
it's not my personal area and i really
don't want to neglect it so why not
start at the top nigel is an amazingly
prolific and influential condensed
matter physicist who works in lots of
different areas but the
number of ideas that are going to get
discussed in this podcast and the way in
which they fit together there's a lot of
ideas and they're tricky and they fit
together an interesting way so i wanted
to do more of a little extended
introduction here than i would usually
do because the forest really matters and
we're going to talk a lot about the
trees so i figured if i could sort of
lay out the road map for the entire
discussion it will help people follow
along when we actually get into it not
because nigel is not clear he's actually
a brilliant expositor of some of these
really difficult ideas but this is the
kind of area where being told what
you're going to be told before you're
told it doesn't hurt any let's put it
that way so here's how i think about
what is going on in this conversation
physics is great right physics is very
very good at describing certain features
of the world but it's natural home
whereas most comfortable most effective
is actually in quite simple systems
right the spherical cow philosophy
ignore air resistance and all that so if
you have just a few particles bumping
into each other do some finding diagrams
or even if you have two black holes in
spiraling or the universe expanding
these might be you know beyond our
intuition or everyday experience but
there's a small number of moving parts
okay
whereas the real world of our everyday
experience actually is very complex
there are many many moving parts in a
biological system or a sociological or
economic system or something like that
and in some sense you know that's a
shame because physics is really good at
what it does and it's kind of a shame
that we can't readily transport the
techniques and
things that we learn from doing physics
into these messy complicated systems
but it turns out there are some physical
systems that are in some sense pretty
simple and yet show features that are
closely related to those that we see in
the real world so think about a fractal
get in your mind the famous images of
fractals with all these little sharp
edges and so forth what makes a fractal
a fractal well that you can look at it
at any magnification and it looks more
or less the same maybe not exactly the
same but sort of the similar statistical
properties so if you zoom in on a
fractal you see just as much going on as
you do if you zoom out and look at it
from very very far away
physicists or other kind of scientists
call this scale-free behavior at every
scale over every distance that you
examine the system something is going on
often called self-similar behavior or
sometimes power law behavior because if
you quantify what's going on you can
show that in these self-similar systems
or fractal systems the amount of stuff
that's going on
goes as the length scale you're looking
at to some exponent to some power okay
so power law behavior very different
than a simple physical system like two
particles bumping into each other or
even a typical condensed matter system
if you think about water
right you can have a glass of water if
you zoom in on it nothing's going on
it's still water
there's no difference it's true from
looking at it one scale to the other but
that's because nothing interesting is
going on there's the scale of the glass
and then nothing going on at the scale
beneath the glass if you have a black
hole two black holes let's say spinning
into each other if you look at it far
away it's just a dot if you look at it
at the scale of the black holes there's
all these black holes you can see two
black holes spiraling into each other if
you zoom in even further you don't even
see the black hole so it's very
different from scale to scale there is a
characteristic scale there
however
go back to the water
water is something that as you know has
different phases right you can take
liquid water you can freeze it to make
ice you can boil it to make water vapor
so there are phase transitions and when
physicists study phase transitions they
often sometimes they think about water
or something like that but very often
they think about magnets we'll talk
right from the start in this podcast
about the ising model uh collection of
little spins that are next to each other
uh well there's a whole bunch of spins
so if you look at two spins that are
next to each other they want to align
with each other because the little spins
are magnets so if you have nothing but
these spins then either they'll all be
pointing up and you'll get a magnet that
way or they'll all be pointing down and
they'll get a magnet pointing in the
other direction because the spins want
to be aligned but if you put that in a
hot room or a hot oven or something like
that if you heat up the system give it a
temperature well then the system the
spins start jiggling around even though
by themselves they want to be lined up
the thermal motions wanted to disorder
them and there turns out to be a phase
transition if you heat it up high enough
who cares about the attraction between
the individual spins lining them up
they're all going to be pointing in
different directions at very high
temperatures so there's some critical
temperature at which you go from being a
magnet being mostly lined up to not
being a magnet at all to everything
being disordered
and this study of phase transitions is
more deep than that and here's why
because if you go right to the point of
the phase transition if you go right to
the temperature at the boundary of it's
a magnet and it's completely disordered
what you see is scale-free behavior what
you see is if you looked at the spins
they would make little domains we call
it a domain if all the spins are in the
same
pointing the same direction in some
region so there are small domains with
just a few spins pointing in the same
direction surrounded by other spins
doing something different there are
large domains where you get a whole
bunch of spins even at this critical
temperature which are all lined up in
the same direction and you can show
mathematically that the distribution of
sizes of the domains of spins at the
critical temperature is scale-free it
looks more or less the same no matter
what scale you look at the ising model
at so here's an example
where physics
methods that study things like phase
transitions and spins and magnets can be
used to quantify and rigorously
understand the behavior of a system that
exhibits scale-free behavior
just like
biological systems like the brain
exhibits scale-free behavior the tree of
life that you get from evolution
exhibits scale-free behavior
things in the economy or in politics or
in social networks
exhibit scale-free behavior so this one
example of critical phenomena phenomenal
phenomena at the critical point where
phase transitions happens is a is a way
for physicists to get their hands and
their quantitative way of thinking about
things on
things happening at different scales
like the real world has and so if you're
good at this like nigel goldenfeld is
you study phase transitions and the
mathematical tools needed to think about
them like the renormalization group is
something that we will talk about and
then you apply it to other areas like
biology and like finance as he has done
very very successfully so we'll talk
about phase transitions and scale-free
behavior and then we'll talk about
biology all the way from the genetic
code to the tree of life that's of
course you know candy for my brain this
is a very mindscape-y kind of thing
where we can connect these ideas from
different areas and nigel goldenfeld is
a master of this kind of stuff i can't
think of a better person to connect
these big ideas for us so let's go
[Music]
nigel goldenfeld welcome to the
mindscape podcast well thank you i'm
happy to be here
so this is one of the challenging
interviews that i sometimes do with a
person who is more senior and
accomplished and there's just too many
things to talk about but maybe we can
start more or less gently with the idea
of phase transitions because i know that
uh people on the street if they may have
heard of the idea of a phase transition
and they're thinking of water boiling or
ice melting or something like that but
the set of connotations that pops up in
a physicist's mind when you say phase
transitions is a little bit different
and richer so you know how do you define
phase transition and what do you what
are the things that you think of
immediately when someone says a phrase
like that
well you can't as a physicist you can't
um
talk about phase transitions without uh
talking about
uh ising models and so uh so uh so most
people most people think about you know
liquids and gases and things like this
which is perfectly correct uh but uh the
the way that physicists uh always use to
think about phase transitions is little
spins on the lattice that can either
point up or all point down and the thing
about them is it is this the
the spins are going to represent say
electronic dipole moments of atoms on a
crystal and they
they interact with their nearest
neighbors but otherwise there is no
global um
coercion for them to do anything but
what's why what people like about phase
transitions is that just because you're
interacting with your nearest neighbor
and if your neighbor is pointing up you
might feel slightly more likely to point
up if your neighbor's pointing down you
might feel slightly more likely to point
down but you know what can happen is
that the tendency can
below a certain uh temperature can
actually propagate throughout the whole
system and so everybody gets uh gets the
point up or points down as a result of
an interaction which is just from your
nearest neighbors so it is a conspiracy
a phrase transition is a conspiracy it's
a cooperative phenomenon you're not
interacting with everybody in the world
but just by interacting with your
neighbors everybody ends up doing the
same thing and that's that's what a
phase transition is and physicists like
to use that simple model
because it's mathematically one where
you can actually you know really
understand in detail what's going on and
in particular
people talk about a phase transition
happening as a function of some
parameter so in the izing model
presumably it's the temperature that
we're imagining changing
yes because you can sort of you know
understand it very qualitatively if if
something is at a very high temperature
that means that they sort of get excited
by by the temperature you know the more
temperature you have the more you move
around and so on that's like an atom in
a gas same thing turns out to be true
for spins going up and down so the
higher the temperature they flip up and
down like this um and so what you would
expect is that very high temperatures
they're all flipping up and down like
crazy and so on average there's going to
be as many pointing up as pointing down
but then as you take the temperature to
be much lower then you know the
temperature really doesn't make much
difference and basically if they can
lower their energy by just lining up
with their neighbors they will do that
and so what you always have is this
interplay between energy trying to you
know minimize the energy by doing the
same thing as your neighbors and then
these sort of
crazy fluctuations induced by
temperature which causes some kind of
disorder and people think of that
disorder using the word entropy and so
the phase transition is a is a is a
trade-off between energy and entropy and
the higher the temperature the more the
entropic effect the lower the
temperature the more the energetic
effect and so then as you dial up the
temperature from a low temperature you
will eventually
go from being in a state where there is
order to a state with disorder and this
search for order and disorder in the
natural universe is something incredible
fundamental and and
physicists call it a phase diagram they
really want to understand the first
question you want to understand about
matter is what is its phase diagram if
you have stuff that does this
how does how does it behave overall and
and this is a question that relates to
physical systems like you know electrons
in a material or spins in a material it
relates to uh phenomena like epidemic
spreading it relates to phenomena in
ecology and in biology um so there's
the applications are
incredible
yeah and but
i think the part that makes sense
i'm imagining that i know nothing about
this now right so i'm playing dumb it's
my job so
the part that makes sense is you know
the spins want to line up but then you
heat them up so they become disordered
and there's some there's some point at
which there's a transition right the
phase transition point some temperature
at which that happens
so okay i figure out what that
temperature is either theoretically or
experimentally is that it am i done or
is there still more to learn about how
this actually happens
well that's a great question um so
you're leading the witness there
because you do actually have a phd in
physics
but um but
the the interesting thing is this what
can happen is as you raise the
temperature you might think or let's say
even lower the temperature so you're
going from a very high temperature to a
low temperature if you're going from
disordered state to an ordered state you
might ask
how does that order emerge does it
emerge bang suddenly or do you just get
into that order gradually and um the
the
something like a liquid gas transition
is something that occurs
just uh
you know suddenly you know you go below
the melting temperature um you in
reality you have to go a little bit
below that
uh if you want to don't if you don't
want to wait forever but uh but once you
go there then your stuff your water
turns into ice and um it doesn't just
turn into a little bit of ice it turns
absorbers it all goes into ice
in in other kinds of transitions like a
magnet
like a superconductor and things like
this many other things that transition
occurs
gradually and
the reason why this is so
interesting is because
the the way that the order emerges as
you lower the temperature
you might think that you could calculate
how much order there is as you go below
the critical temperature but it turns
out to be an incredibly hard problem in
fact when you do the calculation you get
one answer and then you go and do the
experiments and the answer is completely
different from that so that's something
that happens all the time in physics you
have a model of something it doesn't
quite describe things and you say well
you know what you expect it was just a
simple model to begin with but the thing
that was really shocking was that if
if you look at the model the way you've
described the physical system and it
doesn't agree with the experiments
actually there is nothing you can think
of in your description that is
responsible for this discrepancy it's
not like well you just sort of change
this parameter just a little bit and
then you get the third decimal place
correct it's like you can't even
understand in principle how this
discrepancy can
occur and when this was solved and it
took 50 years for people to solve it it
completely changed the way that
scientists and physicists think about
modeling nature
it revolutionizes not just
either study or phase transitions in
material science or solid state physics
it changed the way we think about
elementary particle physics cosmology
high energy physics quantum mechanics
everything changed because we realized
that there was fundamental assumptions
that had gone into our thinking that
made everything get turned on its head
and so the person who ended up uh
putting finishing touches to the theory
that we now have today um you know won
the nobel prize quite quite rightly for
for this work
every year u.s businesses waste over 400
billion dollars because of bad writing
bad writing causes confusion misses the
mark or just takes too long to get to
the point whereas better faster writing
means better business which is why your
team needs word tune for teams going way
beyond simple spelling and grammar
correction word tune is the only ai
powered writing tool that understands
meaning offering writing suggestions
that help anyone achieve clear and
compelling writing word tune will
improve performance on any project from
internal emails to press releases sales
outreach to customer services support
and so much more and you can use word
tune anywhere you're writing online like
google docs slack outlook web and
whatsapp
so now try wartune for free at
wordtune.com
mindscape if you're looking to elevate
your entire team's writing get a
discount today at wordtune.com
mindscape wordtune improves writing
efficiency up to four times and that
means better business so start writing
with wordtune at wordtune.com mindscape
i think that you know
one of the things about the audience for
mindscape is they're not experts in
things but they they they like to hear
some of the details so i think we can
say out loud that you're the person
you're talking about is ken wilson and
the idea is through normalization group
is that more or less right
yep
yep so so how do we uh yeah so how do we
tell our non-expert audience what the
normalization group is and how it solves
this really interesting problem i mean
you're leaving us on tenterhooks here
you have this huge problem
so
i can i can tell you in in in simple in
a simple way so let's let's suppose that
i'm doing an experiment looking at some
phase transition let's say a magnetic
transition i've got a piece of metal in
my lab and i'm doing an experiment
to to measure how the magnetization
number of spins pointing up minus the
number of spins pointing down how that
number changes as i go below the
critical temperature and the
um
and you might say well what what
couldn't the answer depend upon and so
one of the things you might say is well
my experimental apparatus is you know
you know foot in diameter let's say and
perhaps you know you have some reason to
think well maybe it should also depend
on the you know the radius of the earth
so so then you think well by dimensional
analysis the you know one foot divided
by the radius of the earth it's a pretty
small number i should just be able to
just throw that away it shouldn't matter
in in in in in my theory for this and
that's a sort of common sense thinking
that everybody would relate to but that
step turns out to be wrong
okay that step turns out to be the thing
that messes everything up in fact
what it it's not really the radius of
the apparatus divided by the radius of
the earth it's something slightly
different it's actually the the range
over which
these spins
start to communicate
they start to feel cooperation
divided by
the
lattice spacing of the spins on the say
crystal lattice which might be a few
axons
and as you get closer to that
transition
the range over which the cooperative
effects
take place goes as large as you like can
be 100 miles a thousand miles a million
miles if you have a big enough material
um and you would think that range
physicists call it the combination
length
that range um is much much bigger than
the atomic spacing which is angstrom
yeah so we can just neglect
you know the the
the atomic scale in making a model of
this
and
and it makes perfect sense
and everything we teach our
undergraduates in physics by using say
dimensional analysis uses that argument
but it's completely wrong i just there's
something just because something is
small doesn't mean it's negligible and
in the in the phase transition problem
this
fact that this you cannot lose sight of
the small scale if you do you will not
you cannot possibly explain the
experiment you have to include that in
there
that that fact is something i like to
call scale interference okay because
scales that should have by no means have
anything to do with what happens
macroscopically nevertheless do
do show up in the critical behavior and
that that is a real a real a real shock
and just to drum home how big a shock it
is you know people know that the
existence of atoms was only really
established um about 100 or 100 years or
so ago in fact it really was einstein
whose work on ground in motion really
convinced people that atoms actually
exist and so the question that you might
want to ask yourself is why did it take
so long
to discover that matter is made out of
atoms well the answer is
you can explain pretty much everything
that you see in the world around you
mechanical properties thermal properties
and so on without having to assume the
existence of atoms everything happens
in a way that looks just like some
continuum matter is just some blob of
stuff and nothing seems to depend on the
fact that if you really look at it very
closely it's made out of atoms all of
that gets washed away so we're used to
this idea that on large scales all the
micro structure will get washed away and
you never have to worry about it that's
how people in the in the 19th century
were able to work out the theory of
elasticity and fluid mechanics and all
this kind of stuff but it makes perfect
sense that it should happen like this
but at phase transitions all of this
goes out the window
and and so
this was this was why this was such a
shock
to to physicists okay that's a very good
way of putting it and it's interesting
just because you know i've learned
renormalization group
things from the quantum field theory
particle physics perspective and the
even though the ideas are the same the
sort of things you care about are a
little bit different in condensed matter
but this is it's an excellent point that
we don't care how big atoms are or how
far away they are if what we care about
is macroscopic properties unless you're
at a phase transition and so how
how what do we do about that i'm a
little bit scared even asking the
question but you know there are these
ideas of renormalization and we i think
that in many people's minds if they hear
that word at all they're thinking of
feynman and schwinger and tomonaga and
qed but uh it's really in this broader
context that it's applicable to you know
fluids and and materials and and
everything we care about that makes up
the world around us
right so the name renormalization group
uh is related to the normalization that
you have feinman and schwinger and
tominaga
developed to try to solve a completely
different problem at least on the face
of it so the problem the certain maybe i
just mentioned it to your listeners so
the problem that they were concerned
with was uh people tried to you know
work out uh properties of how uh quantum
mechanical systems like atoms interacted
with electromagnetic radiation which
we've known about since the in the
middle of the 19th century and when
people tried to do these calculations um
they they found that when you when you
tried to calculate there is a naturally
small number that comes into the
calculations it's a it's a it's a
dimensionless number i'm not going to
explain what it is it's made up of
things like electronic charge and
planck's constants and things like that
and it's a very small number uh it's
about one you know one over 137
something like this so you think well
okay so i can do this i can't solve this
problem exactly at least i can solve it
uh in an approximation scheme that is
principled and works like that and so
when people tried to do that they
discovered that all their calculations
blew up and and the answer you got was
you know the thing you want to calculate
is something plus infinity plus infinity
squared and so on and so forth and so
that was the big shock where where does
all this come from
and then you know what um you know what
feynman thomas schwinger did was they
figured out a way to say well okay it's
only in finishes if you
if you think about it the wrong way it
but you assume that the mass of the
electron is the actual mass of the
electron that we see but suppose that
mass is something different it's not the
one that we see it's something else and
the one we see is something that has
taken into account these infinities as
it were then they came up with some
mathematical mumbo jumbo that basically
absorbed all these infinities into these
into these unknown quantities that could
not be observed and they were able to
get finite results out of it and feynman
himself didn't believe this was
a good strategy
many times it sort of
you know it's um
you know some leisure demand it's a
mathematical trick and you know why the
heck this works i i i have no idea sort
of thing and and
and so it was treated with suspicion for
a very long time um but the the fact of
the matter is that what people believed
was that the only physical theories that
made any sense at all were theories
where you could do this trick so called
renormalizable theories okay so now what
does that have to do with phase
transitions
when you when you look at phase
transitions and you try to also do
calculations in a small parameter
the small parameter in phase transitions
doesn't turn out to be some number
to do the electric charge or something
like that it's typically something like
a small as a small number that counts
how how how high you are in dimension so
there's an expansion that physicists do
where you expand in in dimensions below
four dimensions okay
turns out that that's the thing that you
you can do and i'm not going to go into
details why so you can say well wait i
live in three dimensions but three
dimensions is one less than four
dimension so why didn't i just think
let's suppose my dimension were actually
3.9 okay so if i if my dimension was
just slightly less than four dimensions
could i do a calculation and if ken
wilson wrote a famous paper critical
phenomena in in the 3.99 dimensions
okay so so you can do things like that
but what you find is that you again
getting infinitives in in these
calculations and so you have to use the
same sort of uh mathematical tricks to
get rid of them but this time you
actually understand what where they come
from and that that's the thing that that
is different
what's happening
and and
maybe it wasn't really clear when wilson
did it but you know
many years later in in the in the late
1980s and 90s i applied these same
things just looking at regular
differential equations that you know you
learn about in high school you can get
these things happening there and you
know what what you find is the when you
do these calculations the the
calculation breaks down because it's
fundamentally making a wrong assumption
it's making the wrong assumption that
the scale you don't have scale
interference but
the cooperative phenomena
you do is so large you don't have to
worry about the atomic spacing that is
wrong and the failure of that
common sense assumption shows up in the
mathematics as infinities in in in the
theory and um
and so now that you understand that so
then you can actually you know put that
small scale back into the problem and
actually see that that solves the the
the infinitives infinity's problem and
and so uh that that's the connection uh
between these things and so a couple of
times now you use the word critical or
or criticality and i want to dig into
that because it's part of the fact that
at or near this phase transition um it's
not just everything happens everywhere
in space for example right there are
fluctuations and you can sort of
characterize them so what do you mean by
the word critical in this context right
so so
so people talk about you know the point
where order first starts to appear so
below that temperature in the case of
say a magnet um
that temperature is called the critical
temperature and all the phenomena the
epiphenomena if you will that are
associated with this weird scale
interference
all of those epi phenomena happen in a
small temperature interval around
that temperature and and and the things
that you see there are you know like a
total breakdown of the usual physical
assumptions and and and so those that's
why those are called critical uh
phenomena now this only happens in the
cases where you have this um gradual
increase in the in in the order it
doesn't really happen in say ice turning
melting and turning into liquid but
physicists call that critical phenomena
and and the the reason why it's so
important is not just that it undermines
it undermines the way we think about
physics we have to start thinking about
physics on different length and time
scales looking at fluctuations looking
at scale invariant phenomena
but it turns out that some of these
effects show up in systems like
biological systems or ecological systems
or the brain things like this and so
people started to realize
that when you look at complex systems
they also show some of the same epic
phenomena associated with critical
phenomena and
so
this
question of trying to understand
critical phenomena then cause physics to
leak into other disciplines and and
infect them with this with this sort of
thing and so you know in neuroscience
and we know now that there are newer
avalanches in the brain which behave
very much like critical phenomena and
and so on and so forth so so so um so
that's another reason why it became so
important well i want to pin this down
exactly because this connection between
something that even though a phase
transition is a little bit more
rich than you know a small number of
particles interacting with each other
that the typical particle physicist
might care about it still seems pretty
simple right a bunch of spins at a
temperature and yet you get these these
phenomena that then are reminiscent of
what happening in the brain or in
evolutionary biology or something like
that and that's that's something worth
teasing out so you you also use the
phrase scale free uh at least once or
twice and so it
what does that mean and is it the same
as critical i i want to get not only the
dictionary definitions but sort of all
the connotations of these words in our
brains
well i don't know
i don't know if i'd say it's the same
thing um
because
um
you would you i mean
when you when you have
critical phenomena so you so so you have
this lattice scale which you're forced
to include in your in your calculations
you have this large scale which is
telling you about the the scale over
which degrees of freedom spins or
creatures or whatever happens to be that
you're describing neurons in the brain
are cooperating and then in between
there's a wide range of scales
and and when you look on in in the in an
intermediate range of scales
there is nothing that tells you in
particular
which scale you're at you you wouldn't
know what scale you're looking at if i
showed you a picture of say spins in a
magnet very close to the critical point
what you would see is eventually you
would see the lattice spacing and that
would then tell you a half that that's
there's a micron there's an angstrom you
know you know what the scale is but if i
didn't put the scale bar on the picture
you wouldn't know what scale you're at
and so we call that scale and variance
and
it leads to very particular mathematical
uh consequences um so another area which
i don't take the opportunity to talk
about is fluid turbulence where also you
get um
you know
fluid motion that is swirly whirly stuff
that swirls and swirls and whirls on all
scales from the large scale like a
hurricane down to you know very small
scales like the mean free path
you know or gases and so well not quite
that scale but but very close to that
and and and so um again there's a
phenomenon where you're not essentially
doing anything to tune the system to a
critical temperature
but the system behaves naturally as if
it is
like a critical system and so you know
that that's that's
why the
phase transition metaphor has become
so
uh so powerful because we are starting
to see we've seen in many systems which
are not phase transitions where you see
the same phenomena and people really
want to understand why
right right right so
for so we go back to the spins
um what you're saying is if i can just
repeat it uh uh in words i think i
understand
we're we're we're zooming in we're
imagining measuring the spins in some
region of space
and or or the average amount of spin in
some little box or something like that
uh and the scale freeness says that if
we look at a big box or a small box uh a
reap big region or small region we see
the same statistical pattern which
sounds like a fractal to me right you
know look looks the same
it's exactly like a fractal exactly like
a fractal and we also see similar
patterns in turbulence or something like
that but now
that raises a huge question because
for the
ising model for the spins the whole
thing seemed pretty delicate right like
you had to tune it to the right
temperature to make this thing happen
whereas turbulence happens all the time
it seems pretty darn robust is that a a
real puzzle or just a fake puzzle
it's a fake puzzle the um
so the analog of tuning the temperature
to the critical temperature is the
analog of making the uh fluid as
turbulent as it possibly can be
and if you want to think about what how
you would do that think about this
suppose i had a very viscous fluid like
honey you know have you ever seen honey
be turbulent
not really no if you made the viscosity
really really small then of course would
be really easy to just put your fingers
into it and swirl it around and so as
you make the viscosity going to zero of
of whatever fluid you're talking about
that tunes you towards the point at
which you would see
complete scaling variants in in a
turbulent fluid
okay so there are fluids so the fluids
if they're less viscous it's easier to
get turbulence in them and sort of that
limit
the the where turbulence is easy is kind
of like the critical point in the that's
right and so if you if if if the
viscosity is some number that is small
but not too not not not too large or not
too small you'll see turbulence over a
range of scales but not over the
complete range of scales we'll be able
to see where its turbulence stops above
and below some scale for example as you
go closer to you know more
less and less viscous fluids that range
of scales
will in where you see turbulent behavior
will increase and it's the same thing as
what happens in magnets as you get
closer and closer to the critical
temperature the range of scales over
which you see fractal behavior in the
sort of configurations of these spins
that range of scales gets larger and
larger
but this is only somewhat reassuring
because isn't turbulence famously the
most difficult problem in classical
physics you know how how close are we to
saying that we truly understand what's
going on in in turbulent flows
well i think it's a great thing that
it's that it's an unsolved problem
because it means that you can write
grant proposals let's try to solve it
right so um so in fact i i
i i lead and i'm part of a
a very
exciting collaboration of people
actually trying to understand uh
terminals um and of course there's many
many ways that people have tried to
understand this and you know what's new
from our perspective is that we're
trying to understand it
using the
conceptual framework of statistical
physics the phase transition framework
as opposed to the
um more traditional in fluid mechanics
framework it's not that they're at odds
with each other but one way of thinking
of it allows you to guess that certain
phenomena might happen
even if you don't really know how to
explain how to solve the equations
exactly and indeed that's what we have
have found for example how how does a
fluid that is
flowing through a pipe as you increase
the speed at which the fluid flows it
should become turbulent
intuitively you would understand that
and when you actually do the experiments
you find that it has all sorts of really
rich
behavior which is can be understood and
predicted um by
the same sort of physics that we use in
phase transitions
some things are just better from home a
home-cooked meal the ability to pause a
movie whenever you want and now with
peloton you can add working out to that
list when you purchase the peloton bike
you get access to live classes and
thousands on demand plus access to the
app to get you moving anytime anywhere
with a boot camp between nap times or a
ride before brunch you can seamlessly
fit peloton into your life what i
personally like about peloton is the
flexibility in the different kinds of
classes you can take it's not just being
on the bike you could do cardio classes
there are strength classes even yoga and
pilates and with epic artist
collaborations and instructor curated
playlists peloton's music experience is
unlike any other with the peloton bike
there's nothing like working out from
home learn more at
1peloton.com new members can try peloton
classes free for 30 days at one peloton
dot com slash app terms apply that's o n
e p e l o t o n dot com
so you just said there if we are flowing
liquid through a pipe which is a very
real world problem by the way i'm glad
that we're doing physics but one that
you know really has
uh applications beyond thinking about
the multiverse or something like that
right you have fluid flowing through a
pipe and you increase the
velocity uh is there a sense in which
there is a phase transition from
non-turbulent to turbulent flow
yes
it's not a sense it's it's an exact
prediction the prediction of that and
only it's a non-equilibrium raised
transition because the fluid is
definitely not in equilibrium it's just
being it has been pushed through the
pipe as it were so it's a
non-equilibrium is what's called a
non-equilibrium phase transition in the
universality class of directed
percolation
and uh and
elaborate a little bit on what that
means
but so that's the prediction and and
that and that has been verified
experimentally in in at least uh one
system um experimentally and in another
in work that we are in the process of
finishing uh writing up in literally in
in pipes now what is directed
percolation okay here's a story okay so
i get up in the morning i like to make
coffee so i make myself a conical filter
i pour in the coffee grounds put it
under the drip and it and it drips
through so this is what happens so you
just put the coffee in and start the
drip filter and you get a cup of coffee
at the end and it's like petrol station
coffee when you get it it's weak and
disgusting and you wouldn't want to
drink it so then you say fine okay
further away just try it again but this
time let's push the grains of coffee
much closer together because you've got
the idea that if the water trickles
through slowly it will absorb some of
the good stuff from the coffee grains
and you'll get a cup of coffee so you go
and do that but what happens then is the
water can't find its way through because
the grains are packed too tightly so the
water backs up and then it spills all
over the counter and then everybody
who's in the breakfast room at that
moment starts yelling at you and uh and
and your nice peaceful day uh stuff is a
rather unfortunate manner so then you
think to yourself okay that didn't work
so maybe i can just get the bands just
right get the grains packed together
just enough that the fluid can still
manage to get through
but
but it takes as long as possible to get
through so it doesn't back up it manages
to get through and absorbs the most
possible good stuff from the coffee
grate and so
you can imagine that there's some
packing threshold where you can manage
to get that where it's not loosely
packed and it's not densely packed it's
just somewhere in between and and that's
and then the water will go through it is
called percolation and and that
percolation point is is a second order
phase transition
and it behaves uh in in in the way that
um you know i've told you it it turns
out that it really mathematically
exhibits the same phenomena as say a
magnet
you know becoming magnetic at the at the
critical temperature but this of course
is not at equilibrium the water is going
through under gravity so it's a
non-equilibrium process and and it's
called percolation because it's
percolating through and it's called
directed because generally speaking when
water goes down it doesn't then start to
come up again right so it is under the
influential gravity so it's called
directed percolation and you can make a
mathematical model of that and the
mathematical model you'd say well let's
make a lattice let's have
sites on the lattice which are you're
not allowed to go to that means there's
a grain in the way and then the fluid
can go through in between them and then
you can ask as as as i vary how many how
many grains there are how much how many
sites there are that you can't go to um
you know how will the particles diffuse
through when you can solve that and and
and so it's a model of particles hopping
on a lattice going all the way through
and trying to tune the
the probability of being able to hop
from one site to another which is
related to how
closely the grains are packed um and you
can solve that and solve that problem
and in a mathematical model
and so so there's there's a description
of something that has nothing to do with
turbulence right right it's just
it's just coffee
pouring through a water pouring through
a bunch of coffee grains and yet
that transition the mathematical
properties of that transition are
exactly what happens when a fluid
becomes turbulent and so this is one of
the this is one of the astounding things
that came from these insights that came
from phase transition physics is that
systems which are totally disconnected
from each other they seem apparently
different nevertheless have exactly the
same mathematical properties and here's
a great example coffee going through a
percolator so water going through a
percolator and a fluid becoming
turbulent one is a discrete model or
something hopping on the lattice and one
is just really just sloshing around and
yet the two things uh behave
mathematically exactly identical at at
this at this transition point and this
is the idea i mean you just sort of
explained in words the idea of a
universality class which is a phrase you
use that these very different physical
systems can uh obey the same equations
under the right circumstances
well it's not just different degree so
there's two things to universality so
you could say let's take a magnet and
let's suppose it's you know some some
alloy or some some so it's got some sort
of atoms in it and i take another magnet
which is made out of completely
different atoms
okay different interactions different
magnetic different electronic properties
and so on what the the first kind of
universality says
that regardless of what atoms it is
the
phase transition happens in exactly the
same way so that's universality number
one
universality number two is
uh actually
it's not it doesn't even have to be a
magnet let's suppose i take the liquid
gas transition
which is just literally a liquid and a
gas okay that transition
can be mathematically related
uh
at the right temperature to the magnetic
transition one hand you've got a magnet
one hand you've got a you know what's
called a lattice gas atoms that are
either there or not and if they're there
you know if there's more of them there
then it's dense it's like a liquid if
there's only a few of them there it's
diluted like a gas and
those two systems are very different but
they can be mapped into each other
water percolating through coffee
granules
obviously very different different
things i mean here's another thing
that's really interesting okay so this
transition also happens in ecology
in other words we have predator and prey
in an ecosystem there's a there is a
there is a
i can explain it to more if you want to
go into this direction but it turns out
that depending on how
voraciously the prey are eaten so how
how veraciously the predators eat the
prey and pray doesn't want to be just
not eaten
now however the predators eat the prey
you can get um like a coexistence where
there's always predator and prey in the
ecosystem
sheep's always walls the population
never goes to zillow and there's a point
where they just coexist and at that
point it's like a phase transition as
well and it also is in this directive
percolation transition
well good i think uh i do
actually explain more about that what is
what what what exactly is it about those
dynamics that maps on to
percolation in some interesting way
well you would never know it just by
looking at it okay you would just say i
have no idea you know if you ask if you
just walk down the street you know
found a physicist and asked her you know
what do you think this this transition
is going to be there's no way she would
say oh it's going to be directed
calculation in the ecosystem
so so
you you have to you have to study it uh
you know with with statistical physics
techniques but really what it ends up
being is that
you you have to have what's called an
absorbing state a state that once you
get into it then you can't get out of it
again and um so so that it really is is
is one of the the key factors that turns
out to tell you whether something is is
is in such a state so if for example in
an ecosystem if you know if you eat all
the prey then
then the predators
the prey are dead the predators have now
got nothing to eat so they die
everything dies and then the ecosystem
is then just dead forever so that's
that's that's an example of an absorbing
state in in the fluid turbulence case it
turns out that if you're looking at say
a flow in a pipe
um
you know if you make the flow just be
landlord and then you increase the speed
at which you make the fluid flow through
the pipe and you do it really really
carefully you can actually
as high as you want to go in speed if
you do it really really carefully of a
very smooth pipe there's no vibration
nothing like that the the
the fluid will always stay laminar and
then you know you could be
you know have a very high velocity fluid
going through the pipe and you say how
can this not be
and all of a turbulent that that amount
of vibration is enough
it is turbulent okay good
so there's a kind of gap uh you know
mathematically it's called a subcritical
transition um and it's that that that
gap that means that if you're in the
laminar state you can literally stay
there forever in principle
unless something comes along and
perturbs it so in this is i just want to
get as explicitly as possible the
relationships between these very
different physical systems so in one the
critical
point is where the flow is at a certain
rate where it could stay laminar or it
could become turbulent and the other the
rate at which the prey is being eaten
the rate at which the sheep are being
eaten by the wolves is such that the
both populations stay exactly the same
is that right
yes
and it's not really unique how you do
that you could say it's a characteristic
speed at which the fluid flows through
the pipe given that you know the
viscosity of the fluid or you could say
never mind the speed just vary the
viscosity or or you know
or this or the diameter of the pipe or
in the case of the predator and prey the
birth rate of the of the prey for
example
you know think about this way i've got
some wolves they can eat at a certain
rate okay they're eating they're eating
sheep let's suppose the sheep are like
rabbits and they they reproduce you know
every
you know 100 years okay not like rabbits
the opposite they reproduce every 100
years and what's going to happen is this
is the wolves are going to eat all the
sheep and then they'll they're gone then
the walls will die and that's the end of
it if on the other hand the sheep can
reproduce every one minute of course
they really can't but it's not supposed
to be they could then you know the
wolves just wouldn't be able to keep up
they're trying to eat deep and meanwhile
the sheep are making new baby sheep and
so on and so forth and so then you'd say
well then they they keep up and so
there's now coexistence of the two
things and so then you can ask well what
birth rate do i need somewhere between
once a minute and once every hundred
years there's going to be some critical
birth rate where the sheep you know
pretty much eat all the
all the wolves eat all of the sheep um
but they but the sheep just managed to
make enough babies that the system
doesn't die out completely and so so so
again it's this balance
in this particular example that's what
it would be
maybe someday in the future we'll live
in a post-scarcity world and then your
company can waste money on inefficient
hiring if it wants to until then save
your time and only pay for quality
candidates that meet your must have
requirements by going to indeed indeed
is the job site that makes hiring
incredibly simple just attract interview
and hire in fact with indeed you can do
all of your hiring in one place
including the interviewing so don't just
hope your perfect candidate will find
you indeed's hiring tools help you cut
through the noise to hire faster and
smarter in fact indeed instant match
provides a list of quality candidates
whose resumes are on indeed the moment
you post a sponsored job with indeed you
save time and money by setting your
must-have qualifications and only paying
for the quality candidates that meet
them so get started right now with a 75
dollar sponsor job credit to upgrade
your job post at indeed.com
mindscape that's a 75 credit at
indeed.com mindscape indeed.com
mindscape offer valid through september
30th terms and conditions apply
and do we expect that i i honestly don't
know the answer this question although i
can guess it do we expect that at that
critical point where the rate of uh
wolves eating sheep and sheep
reproducing is just right to keep it uh
a long-term balance
is there scale-free behavior if we had a
really really big ecosystem and sort of
zoomed in is it sort of the similar
fluctuations yeah
yes yes
it's it's scale free in fact uh it's
mathematically identical to what happens
in high energy hadron scattering so you
may you may remember from grad school
you know you probably studied reggie
polls and reggie on the field theory
yeah i mean
okay so so
reggie on field theory i'm not really
you can explain that better than i can
but region field theory was an attempt
to understand
the
high energy scattering and it turns out
mathematically to be
to be the same as this process of of of
directed percolation and it is a a scale
invariant uh except it's an anisotropic
scale invariance so you you think of
scale and variance as being every
direction you look looks the same in
these problems things look different in
different directions so for example
think about the water dribbling through
the coffee in the in the in your
percolator right so obviously the
vertical direction is very different
from the horizontal direction
okay and so so when you get the critical
phenomena in that process
the way that
that you get scaling variance in this in
the vertical direction is different from
the way you get
scaling variance in the horizontal
direction and that's because the system
is out of equilibrium it's being driven
the water is has to follow the gravity
and go go down but it can go sideways as
much as it likes it just can't go back
up and so um
and then so that that process
is anisotropic and that again that's
something that's very special to these
non-equilibrium
phase transitions
and i'm going to return to my question
about the the delicateness here um so we
see or maybe maybe the right way to ask
it is
when we see other scale-free behavior in
nature
um
is there
what is it about it that is phrase
transitionee
in other words when we see critical
behavior in the brain or in a hurricane
or whatever
um why is it approximately scale and
variant rather than just having a scale
that dominates everything is there is
there
even though it's not tuned to some
critical point as far as i know yeah so
that's right so that i think that's the
sort of
you know million dollar question i mean
i think people people don't really know
is it really true that there was nothing
tuned
in there or you know it's not really
understood let me give you an example of
how you can fool yourself into thinking
that there was no tuning so um many
years ago maybe
maybe 20 or 30 years ago
people um you know led by uh power back
for example at uh uh in in
in denmark um
made models of sand piles you know you
take a take a you take some sound grains
you put them onto a pile and beach and
you make a sand sand pile out of it and
then of course as the sand pile gets
bigger and bigger when you put the last
grain on
uh what will happen is it'll cause a
little avalanche and and and so people
started to realize that if you made
models of this that this process this
avalanche process in sand piles
exhibited this
the scale-free behavior that you're
talking about and so this seemed like
well this is a really you know nobody
tuned anything you're just putting sand
grain stacking them up making a making a
making a pyramid at the beach you know
nothing's being tuned there so so it was
sort of thought that maybe somehow the
system self-organizes itself and it
became a self-organized self-organized
criticality
so then um
sid nagel one of my colleagues at the
who's at the university of chicago said
well i'm going to test this
experimentally so he went and got sand
grains and built a you know nice
apparatus and some really clever
measurements which is sort of what's
what sid does
and uh and what he discovered that in
the real
real sand piles they're not scale
environment
and what had happened was that in making
the models people had neglected the
inertia of the grains
and
so the real the real one doesn't show
that because of because of this and so
by making the mathematical models you
actually had inadvertently tuned it to a
critical point by saying well i don't
need to worry about inertia so i'll just
set that equal to zero ignoring
something
is the same as setting it equal to zero
and setting it equals zero is the same
as tuning it
so
so so you know so we we know that we can
easily fool ourselves into thinking that
there's a self-organization that's
really not there it's just an artifact
of the way we've been
talking about the farm
that makes perfect sense that in our
attempts to mathematically model
something we simplify we find ourselves
at a special point due to those
simplifications but then there there's
also the
the opposite of that where
you know i think that in something like
evolution i think that you it's
somewhere in the many talks you've given
on many subjects uh you mentioned that
phylogenetic trees the way that we trace
down speciation uh in biological
evolution
uh can be thought of in some sense which
maybe you'll you'll explain as scale
free um
uh where i don't think anyone tuned it
there unless we want to believe in
intelligent design i think that it just
sort of happens so is there scale
freeness in evolution and and and why is
that
well there there is but there is a there
is a hidden tuning though so so
so so let me just explain what you're
what you're talking about so you can so
the thing is this uh you can everybody
knows about what a family tree is okay
so you you know your your family tree is
you know who is descended from you and
then who do they marry and make children
and stuff like that so people make make
family trees so then you can say well
all right can we make a family tree but
now we're talking about species rather
than
you know human human beings and we're
seeing you know what species uh
you know uh humans descended from and
what species were they descended from
and so on and so forth you know all the
way back okay and try to figure out uh
you know what was the evolutionary
history of all life uh on earth and um
you know the first person who who really
answered that question i mean the
question was posed you know a long time
ago you know even darwin drew a picture
of us or family tree of life and um
my my uh my colleague and friend uh
carl woes was the really the first
person to come up with a way to answer
this question empirically and in fact
did that and discovered how to make uh
phylogenetic trees of all life on earth
just discovered the
evolution of history and what he
he did it using a sort of molecular
sequencing technique which is the
forerunner of today's genomics and and
what he discovered was that um you know
life is actually in three parts um
people knew that there were
you know
bacteria which are little round blobby
things um people knew that there were
eukaryotic cells like humans or plants
where the cell is much more complicated
internal structure biologists would say
it has a nucleus and then what he
discovered was hey guess what there's
another set of round blobby things and
that look just like bacteria if you
don't look at them closely enough
and yet they have a totally different
evolutionary history
and um and so that was the
discovery of the what's called the third
domain of life and then once he had
discovered it wasn't shown that they had
totally different evolutionary history
from
you know from
humans and plants and things like this
and bacteria um you know then people
discovered
you know other differences you know to
do the cell walls and so on so so so now
you can make these phytogenetic trees by
doing genome sequencing and and when you
when you do that you discover that the
trees that you make where the length of
the branches tells you how many um
mutations that have been in the dna
those trees turn out to be
mathematically fractal if you draw them
out they look fractal and if you study
them
topologically and actually how you do
that is is really
too involved to talk about here
but it's easy
to talk about roughly speaking how many
clays or branches emanate from one
particular species and you can still
count that up and
and then sort of count how many in total
are
connected from it and the mathematical
relationship between those tells you
about how symmetrical the branching
pattern is you know if you have you know
people who then
make babies and then they each make two
babies and make two babies off that you
get a tree that bifurcates into two of
each generation on the other hand it
could be that one one branch bifurcates
into three one branch bifurcates doesn't
[ __ ] at all and so you can get
asymmetric trees and and it turns out
that the way the
characterization of that asymmetry of
the trees turns out to follow a scale
invariant
behavior and that's that's what um
that's all was discovered about about 10
10 years or so ago um by us also
independently and a bit earlier
by another group and um
and what we discovered was that actually
this
could be an outcome of the interplay
between ecology and evolution and
and and the idea being that
that when
organisms
change their environment by their
activity i think you know the usual
example is beavers you know eating trees
damming rivers causing lakes and then
getting invaded by
plants and fish and things like this so
so the activity of an organism in its
environment can literally change the
evolutionary history of that entire
ecosystem and and so when you try to
model that effect in a very in a very
crude way what do you find is that it
also it can produce this scale invariant
behavior so then to your question your
question was well what does that have to
do with the tuning so
remember that we talked about the scale
interference in the magnetic system that
there's a vein over which there is a
times a spatial scale where things are
correlated there's a range where the
atoms sit on the lattice which is
angstroms and it's the scale
interference between that very small
scale in space and a very large scale in
space for the correlations that scale
interference the fact that you can't
neglect the smallness of the lattice is
what causes the critical phenomena so in
the
evolution problem it's an it's a
normalization effect like that of scale
interference but it's in time
rather than a space
so when you think about ecosystems you
think there's a time scale which the
ecosystem adjusts when you think about
evolution you think there's a time scale
over which evolution occurs you know
millions and millions of years and you
would think well i can neglect you know
the time scale of beavers eating over
here trees and chopping them down and
causing a mess in in in the ecosystem
and damning rivers i could ignore that
time scale compared to millions of years
well it turns out you can't
and if you if you make values if you ask
what happens if you don't make that
common sense assumption then you can
explain the
the fractal behavior the scaling laws
that you see in in the evolutionary
history of of uh of life alert
so it is an interesting kind of tuning
in some sense i mean
the the ising model example gives us the
impression that you know we are an
external actor and we have to carefully
tune it whereas
in in examples like this i think
probably both turbulence and in
evolution there's some internal dynamics
that naturally takes you to that
critical point is that a fair thing to
say
that's right in other words in the limit
if you just look at the evolutionary
time scale as being just a little bit
bigger than the ecological time scale
you will not see this scale invariant
behavior so just like in the in the
fluid if the viscosity is small but not
zero but not tending towards zero you'll
see turbulence over some range but you
won't see a full scale variance so the
same thing is true in the in the
ecological uh evolutionary time scales
that the
the uh this time scale of the evolution
is so much larger than the time scale
of
physical processes in in the environment
that's the t that's the hidden tuning
parameter those causes to handle it it
does seem like there is a potential
worry for scientists here because
we see approximately scale-free behavior
in many different kinds of systems you
already mentioned the brain there's also
things like the internet or the economy
as well as evolution and turbulence and
so is there a worry that
if the phenomenon is too universal it's
hard to explain because almost any kind
of dynamics gives rise to it i mean how
do we go backwards from what we observe
about the system to why it is like that
yeah
it's it's a really great question and
the answer is you can't so universality
is a double-edged sword on the one hand
it means you can explain a phenomena
without having to know very much about
it
mathematically for a physicist i want to
understand a phase transition i just
need to understand that use the symmetry
group and the dimension of the
dimensions spatial dimensional system
and once i know those things i can
predict what the what the critical
phenomena are going to be um and as you
as we've already talked about
those can be independent of what the
actual system really is you know whether
it's a magnet or or it's um you know a
liquid gas transition or people in a
city or something like this so you have
this great universality so you have this
huge explanatory power but then if you
want to ask well what's really going on
at the microscopic level why is it like
that um you don't really you don't
really know so let me give you a
concrete example of where this is this
turned out to be a huge problem and that
is ecology so you can ask a very simple
question about an ecosystem you can ask
how how
how um
you know what what's going to be the
most abundant organism in the ecosystem
and then what's going to be the next
most abundant and what's going to be the
next next most abundant and so you can
you know calculate
you know
measure a species abundance diagram you
know how many species are there which
have this sort of abundance how many
species are there which have this sort
of abundance and so on and you can draw
that distribution out you can you can
measure it and the place where it's
really been measured is um in a place
called colorado island which is near
panama where uh there's
you know every tree and shrub and weed
has been analyzed by by biologists and
botanists who know what they're doing
and they can identify these things so we
have extremely good ecological data for
that for that system and so you can say
well okay so let me try to make a theory
for how this you know this species
abundance distribution you know i'm
going to take into account you know how
things grow and they compete for light
and the soil nutrition and you know all
these sort of things that you might
imagine are really important okay so you
can do that and you'll get some
distribution
then you can say well i didn't really
care about that because
you know here's what i know as as a
statistical scientist i know that
something has to be more more um
abundant than something else so
so and then the next thing is going to
be more abundant than the third thing
and so on so let me ask let's suppose
that the
the organisms were completely
independent they never saw each other
they behaved exactly the same
functional uh equivalence is what a an
ecologist would call it and so you make
a theory for how things interact in an
ecosystem which is like the ideal gas
theory of atoms bouncing around in the
box in other words there's no
interactions they just bounce out in the
box and they obey statistical laws and
those statistical laws end up giving you
the laws of thermodynamics and you know
the ideal gas law that you learned in
high school and things like that so you
say let's try to do that the species is
an ecosystem and you go ahead and you do
that so that's called the neutral model
of ecology
and uh and it was really uh you know
really promulgated extensively by
brilliant work by hubble and many other
people you know about 20-25 years or so
ago and so so now you look at what you
predict from that and you look at what
you predict from actually understanding
the biology of the organisms
and you get two distributions and
they're virtually exactly the same
so when i look at buyer colorado island
i ask well
was this just
is this a curve just a statistical
thing like the central limit theorem
which is of course the first example of
universality in in science that
that
i know about um or is it does it reflect
something about the actual processes by
which this community was formed and
there's been a huge debate in the
ecological literature about this and of
course the right answer is it's a
mixture of the two things but how how
does one you know go backwards well the
answer is you can't really what it tells
you is that asking for species abundance
distributions is a question that is you
know nice to know may be useful for some
things
but um it's not going to answer the
question about process so just because
you see a pattern
doesn't mean you understand what is the
process that gave lifestyle exactly but
okay this this sparks another question
which
you'll tell me whether or not it's
related the use of the word universality
in all of these examples um
uh
gives a feeling of robustness for the
kinds of phenomena that we're talking
about so given that we're talking about
life and and its relationship to physics
an obvious question is how robust is
life itself i mean are you someone who
thinks that we're going to find
life uh ubiquitous in different
hospitable environments in the universe
or is this something where we need to
know extra information about some
miraculous fluctuation that started it
all
no i i i my prejudice is is that
life is a generic consequence of the
laws of physics and that
um that
matter can
self-organize
uh out of equilibrium hierarchically
into into structures that are then
evolvable
and it's the evolvability that in my
view defines living systems not not that
they can reproduce not that they can
metabolize things but that they are
capable of evolving into uh what is
called open ended growth of complexity i
mean you could say well okay so life
started some you know the mother of all
faith transitions you know
3.8 billion years ago okay so now you've
got self-replicating uh rna molecules if
you believe the rna world
but you know let's suppose you believe
that so then the question is okay so
once once you've got self-replicating
rna molecules why didn't it just
stop why why why do why does it have to
go and produce you know all this isn't
and elephants and humans and dinosaurs
okay so that question of how the growth
of complexity arises is really i think
one of the frontier
frontier questions in evolutionary
biology um
so so yes i i do think that
that life that there is an inevitability
about life i don't know about robustness
um i think the inevitability is is the
way the world i would use well one of
the points that is often mentioned in
this context is that life seemed to
begin relatively quickly after the
formation of the earth but it but it
didn't as far as we know seemed to start
many different times or is that
something we don't know
i would say it's something we don't know
so i think the the speed at which life
evolved is really an important question
and and it's actually one that i worked
on um in understanding the the genetic
code um
because you know you know the world is
about 4.6 billion years uh we know from
fossil evidence and
you know
genomics that really the last
universal common ancestral state of life
from which we are seemingly all
descended uh was about 3.8 billion years
ago maybe even earlier but certainly 3.8
so you know
you know the earth was pretty
inhospitable tonight for a large part of
its early history but yet within less
than a billion years you essentially
evolved the complexity more or less the
complexity of the modern cell
and then after that evolution didn't
really do much i mean you made dinosaurs
and humans and things like that but but
from the point of view of the
architecture of the cell from the point
of view of the information that is
transmitted and so on you know there
wasn't really very very significant um
changes on from the point of view in the
qualitative point of view and so that
that's always been uh a an important and
important question and um
well if you if you're interested we can
talk into how that that paradox uh is
resolved but um you know i i do think
that there is uh going back to the
inevitability i think the thing that you
you really want
i'd like your listeners to take away
is that you know what life is is a
process by which a planet
approaches equilibrium
so the purpose if you want to know you
know what is the meaning of life what is
the purpose of life
the the purpose of life is to help
planets approach equilibrium because
what life does is it it takes
chemical potential differences in the
environment when a planet first forms
there's lots of
metastable states there's lots it is far
from equilibrium there's chemical
processes that will eventually you know
cause chemical reactions to occur and
what life is able to do is short-circuit
those reactions and basically suck up
that energy difference and that energy
difference of free energy difference as
you should say it is then what is used
to power living systems and so living
systems are always involved in a
competition
with just regular chemical processes but
living systems have an advantage because
they can exchange information
and so they can swap information through
swapping genes they can
they can you know
by evolution they're able to
um adapt to environments change the way
in which they operate in ways that
purely chemical systems don't do and so
living systems are the things that
really exploit these environmental
free energy differences and suck up
every last bit of free energy
and and that's that's what that's the
purpose of life
kind of humbling
i like to quote
michael russell
taught me
that the purpose of life is to
hydrogenate carbon dioxide and i think
that that's just sort of a cheeky way of
saying exactly the same thing you're
saying it's part of that exactly and
just for the vocal i've been heavily
influenced by it by by
this point of view is not solely my own
point of view of course but
it's one that has emerged from the
community of scientists trying to
understand the emergence of life okay
but you left us hanging with a paradox
that i think the paradox was why things
happened really really quickly and then
slowed down and nothing interesting has
happened in evolution for the past four
billion years so yeah help us out why
why is that
where's the phase transition oh there
you go so they should have guessed
so so the thing is this um
the the the way
carl rose and calif and i turned this
question into something that is a
scientifically answerable question
which is not very easy i have to i have
to add because these things are so
speculative and they occurred so long
ago so you would think that this isn't a
scientifically well-defined question but
it turns out it really is and and the
way the way we
we approached it was was building off on
work that looked at the structure of the
genetic code so the genetic code just to
make sure everybody knows what i'm
talking about here it's not
um your genome you know if you look at
the newspapers they'll say you know
somebody's genetic code and they're just
being you know the sequence of
nucleotide bases on somebody's genome
the genetic code is a thing that's that
tells the ribosome
you know it's a machine inside your
cells and it makes proteins and the way
it makes proteins is it reads messenger
rna in groups of three nucleotide bases
and those are called codons and and each
group of three then tells the ribosome
or you need this particular amino acid
go and grab it and stick it onto the
protein that you're just making and this
machine called the ribosome that's
that's all it does and and the code
the genetic code is the thing that tells
you from a space of
nucleotide bases and triplets to the
space of amino acids it's that map now
there's four
nucleotide bases they occur in triplets
so there's four times four times four
which is 64 different combinations and
yet
there's 20 only 20 amino acids of life
and so there's a
a non-unique another one-to-one map that
goes from one space to another and
that's the thing called the genetic code
and so when you when you study the
genetic code in detail um what you find
is of course everybody knows that every
organism on the planet has the same
genetic code it's not quite true there's
small variations um but this but it's
more or less true so maybe we shouldn't
say the genetic code is universal maybe
we should just say it's canonical okay
so now you've got this genetic code so
then you ask well if i had to ask you
you know you mentioned intelligent
design so let's let's do some
intelligent design how would i design
the genetic code well the way i would do
it is this i'd say well look this
ribosome machine that goes around making
proteins in your cells um you know it's
going to make lots and lots of mistakes
there's all sorts of fluctuations on
scales you know the the molecules have
to move around inside the cell what
happens if you can't get the one you
want and stuff like this so there's all
sorts of bad things that can happen and
and so it could very well be the case
that this machine stitches together the
wrong amino acids into the protein that
you're supposed to make and then you get
a protein that's
you know really bad for you and then
you'll die and so on so then you might
say okay well suppose i had to design
into the genetic code in such a way that
if i get the wrong amino acid
i'm still going to get one that is more
or less
chemically like the one i should have
got so that the protein has some chance
of
folding up in just the way it's supposed
to fold up so they can do the stuff that
it's biologically supposed to do yeah
okay so if you were really clever you
could sit down and design your genetic
code that does that okay or you could
just wait four billion years or actually
half a billion years and evolution will
do it for you and so the genetic code
has this structure it is pretty much
not quite but pretty much optimal in the
sense of having a structure so it will
minimize the most frequent errors that
you're going to get in this
gene expression process and and that was
discovered by people like hagenhurst in
the in the in the 1990s and elaborated
on by many others including myself and
over the following 10 years or so but
then what we discovered was actually you
know how does this process happen um
dynamically
and you might say
well it can't happen dynamically because
we're all descended from one organism or
one group of organisms you can't really
tell
we know that from carlos's work and and
the subsequent elaborations so there was
a last universal common ancestor well
whatever genetic code that organism had
or that group of organisms had we must
have that as well
and so you would say okay it's an
accident but it's also a frozen accident
because let's suppose that you say
halfway through the price of evolution
i'm going to change
the
the genetic code table i can put this
genetic code table on a t-shirt okay i'm
going to just change it swap it swap
things out put some amino acids in a
different place
well then you'd make proteins that would
be all completely wrong and the organism
would be suboptimal or it would die so
in france is crick realized this in 1968
and so you know basically the idea is
the genetic code is a frozen accident it
can't evolve it's just what it is and
that's the way it is no point in trying
to analyze it okay so we know that that
was wrong and so how did it evolve and
and and i'm not going to go into a huge
amount of detail about this um but
you know the story is that actually
what happened
is
since about 3.8 billion years ago life
has evolved in a tree-like structure
like a family tree just like we've been
talking about for the last half an hour
so
before that the only way you can get
a unique genetic code an optimal genetic
code and a fast genetic code meaning one
that evolves fast is if the process of
evolution is not tree like
so you think of you know you have a
family tree
it's got to be a tree right but it's not
true at the biological level
and the reason is this
when you're tracking a family tree of
organisms what you're tracking actually
are genes that are involved in the
that code for parts of the ribosome
because it's such an essential
ingredient of life and this was one of
cowboys brilliant insights so
so you know that's the same in all
organisms so that's how that's what you
except for small differences and that's
what you use to trace the family tree so
what we realized was that before three
billion years ago actually organisms
could swap
genes
collectively not just transmit them to
their offspring to their daughter cells
but actually transmit the genes to
an organism to which they're not related
right just like i'm teaching my my class
on the normalization group like going
back to what we talked about at the
beginning of this podcast all right well
you know i could tell people go and read
my book come to my lectures and after
after several months of torture you'll
know how to do these things um
on the other hand wouldn't it be great
if i could just sort of pop out a little
loop of dna
throw it into the audience everybody
absorbs that loop of dna and then bingo
they can do they can they can do
renaultization group calculations well
we can't do that obviously but bacteria
can and they do it all the time and and
and that process happens today is called
horizontal gene transfer
horizontal meaning to organizations that
are not related to vertical being giving
genes to your own children so that's
vertical horizontal
and
that that process uh is a very very fast
way for an evolving system to discover
solutions to problems to be able to
evolve because it's now
it's now utilizing a network effect
rather than just making you know copies
of itself with small variations and so
when you
model that and and and work out what
happens you find it it you get hugely
accelerated uh evolution rates uh you
you go to a unique and an optimal uh a
genetic code
and and there's even evidence now when
you start looking at
the phylogenetic trees for the
uh for the molecules that are involved
in the gene expression process the
so-called amino acid trna synthesis for
example you could see evidence of these
these horizontal gene transfers way back
in in early time and you can even see it
in recent
x-ray uh data uh of high high resolution
x-ray data um
showing you the structure of the
ribosome showing you that it evolved in
the kind of successive
series of onions onion layers that
evolved so in the middle you've got a
thing called the peptide transferase
center which which does translation but
it does it really really crappily and
then later on it gets more and more
more and more accurate and this
crappy translational
procedure that's at the core of the
ribosome is essential for its ability to
evolve
because if it can if it's a very
valuable process then it's one that can
that can evolve over time and we we
worked out what kind of dynamical system
uh we do that and we model that and
stimulated it and so on and and that's
yeah that's how i try to understand
well it's another example of something
that appears accidental or tuned but in
fact there's a dynamical explanation the
the genetic code is the thing that you
would naturally evolve to under these
kinds of constraints
that's right and it's more than that
because the system eventually goes from
a state where you're having a lot of
horizontal gene transfer to a point
where it cuts off the horizontal gene
transfer and the only thing that is left
at least for the core cell machinery is
vertical
vertical evolution because once you've
got once you've got a really good
ribosome
you know you don't want to you don't
want to start messing around with it
and also any anything you get that
that you you get from another organism
is very unlikely to improve the thing
you've got and so this process naturally
self-limits
so this has been fantastic let's to wrap
up get a little bit more meta because
we've we've traversed a lot of fields
implicitly right from canoes matter
physics there was some particle physics
in there you know biology evolutionary
biology cellular biology complex systems
um yeah we did it we did a really poor
job of staying in that lane i know we're
well which is bad but you know is it
good
it's good exactly so i mean what what is
the
i guess my question is how conscious is
this of a choice on your part in terms
of the research you do is it that you
just led to interesting problems and
they end up being all over the map or do
you do you place value on being all over
the map in some sense
uh i i
i place value on being all over the map
and in the following in the following
sense i like to work on problems that if
i didn't work on them nobody else would
have done them
and and my my theory of impact in
science is that your impact is the ratio
of what you can do
in the numerator to what everybody else
does in the denominator and what you do
in the numerator is bounded above by how
lucky you are how much funding you have
by how smart you are you know
all sorts of things like that so and you
know i'm not really very smart so i i
know that my numerator is bounded so i'm
not going to try to make that big but i
can do is make the denominator as small
as possible and and so i try to work on
problems that other people aren't
working on i try to look for things
you know intellectual arbitrages where i
can see something i know in one field is
similar to what happens in another field
one of those fields will be ahead of the
other so whatever which falls ahead take
what it knows and apply it to the other
field and things like that some
physicists are i'm not the first person
to do this by any against physicists or
all the time and and so that's a that's
a that that's that's sort of a way why
these things um why my work is
definitely
wandered all over the map there is a
similarity and a coherence to it
there are connections between these
things
that you know my students and i
see
and it and it drives us to we see these
analogies and we say well we can we can
do this you know we should do that i
mean like right now i'm working on
something to do with uh with uh with
time crystals oh okay
yes i'm not going to tell you what they
are what the analogy is because because
the idea is the is the main thing in in
in physics as you know but um you know
you see these connections and then you
and then once you see the connections
then then then it um
you know it percolates through to other
other fields i know we didn't even get
to touring patterns or hallucinations or
the visual cortex or anything like that
but uh
it's uh uh i will point people to your
uh web pages and and your articles are
you ever ever gonna
well i appoint people to wonderful art
articles written by jennifer willett
exactly on exactly those topics
exactly should i should do that also by
the way are you ever going to write a
popular book is that an ambition
yes it is an ambition and it's one that
i've talked with um
publishers
about for some for some time for
actually about nearly 20 years yeah and
i will i will do it when i have a bit of
time because nobody has written
the uh the trade book that describes
what condones metaphysics is um nobody
even knows the field exists yes it's so
fundamentally important um so that's one
thing but i've got there's lots of other
things that i that i think are
interesting to talk about so um
so yeah so i think i i definitely have
ideas about that but i don't have the
time to do it right now well i will do
it yeah well we'll be waiting for it
nigel goldenfell thanks so much for
being on the mindscape podcast
and it's been my pleasure and thanks for
your awesome questions
[Music]
you